[Music]
forget the electric chair forget the
foreign squad the us state of arizona is
planning to bring back the gas chamber
to execute its death row inmates and not
just that
the gas they plan to use could form the
same poison found in
zyklon b a lethal gas used by the nazis
what let's have a little look you heard
that correctly
arizona is preparing to use chemicals
that nazis used to auschwitz
and have recently refurbished their gas
chamber the guardian
obtained heavily redacted documents
through a public records request
showing arizona's department of
corrections splashing out on over
two thousand dollars worth of
ingredients that make hydrogen cyanide
gas
nazi era chemicals using that particular
gas has caused uproar given its
well-known ties to the holocaust with
the executive director of the death
penalty information center saying
if they say we'll carry out the law
because it's the law that's a bit like
saying we're just following orders and
we know where we've heard that before
if they say they were aware of the
history and they didn't care that's even
worse
the state put a halt to executions back
in 2014 after mucking up death row
inmate joseph woods lethal injection
taking nearly two hours to kill him it's
only supposed to take about two minutes
and ironically back in 1999 arizona was
the last state to use the gas chamber
itself but had to stop
using it because you guessed it they
mucked it up
killer walter legrand suffered pure
torture choking and gagging for a
whopping 18 minutes before dying with
robert dunham adding
states have proven themselves capable of
watching almost everything when it comes
to executions
they've also proven themselves capable
of blatantly disregarding the law
nothing about this helps their
trustworthiness in administering capital
punishment
arizona currently has 119 people on
death row and two inmates have already
been placed on the gas chamber list
let's just hope it's not third time
unlucky for arizona's department of
corrections
and their dodgy execution methods